I mean you should have seen her looking
mr. blinks face when I ordered it man I
mean it's like he wanted to educate me
right there on the spot
[Music]
we got a legend you're so big Michael
big man you can growing up it was one of
my favorite players of all time is you
and Brett for more or less at least I
made the list
so Mike your rookie year with the
Atlanta Falcons what was your most
memorable moment you had with owner
Arthur Blank
so my rookie year I wasn't too fond of
going out to eat you know maybe like
Ruby Tuesday's or Friday so I'm used to
a different type of menu you know coming
out of college after you invited me out
to dinner you know so I'm thinking okay
you know it's my first time going out to
dinner with you know the guy who just
bought the team he it's the big time you
know money man you know Home Depot and
I'm like I'm really not ready for this
but you know I'm gonna go you know being
the quarterback of the team so we get to
the restaurant stony River out in
Alpharetta I never forget we going I'm
looking at this fancy menu and
everything look like it's like Chinese
language - man look I'm used to seeing a
certain type of menu not you know a menu
of you know this bag go to where you
know it's just made me young and
porterhouse steaks and I don't even know
anything about that I barely knew with
the work on treatment how big was to me
it's about four pages you know Fridays
and some you got to two pages max you
know I'm saying with the drink menu so
you know I'm looking at the menu and I'm
like what do i order you know without
embarrassing myself or without borders'
something might cost way too much so I'm
looking at the menu I'm gonna be the
most simplest thing man I bought chicken
tenders and french fries it's fresh out
of college man that's the best I could
do honestly mr. Blayne looking at me
like are you serious I'm like yeah
because I'm not gonna put this bill how
much were those chicken tenders and
fries at a steak
probably the cheapest thing on the menu
and I don't know if they came off the
appetizer sad but I would say no more
than $20 Meg please tell me you had some
other different sounds besides ketchup
think I had the ranch dressing man I
went with the ranch dressing in May you
should have seen him looking mr. blinks
face when I ordered it man I mean it's
like he wanted to educate me right there
on the spot but you know I was a 21 year
old kid coming from where I came from
and fresh out of college but we ate
cheese steaks and fries every day man so
it wasn't the best diet but I was just
making my adjustments you said you
didn't know if Arthur Blank will pick up
the check or not how did he end up
coming to inclusion and he got the check
it was my first time I was sitting down
meeting somebody that power you know
that statute you know so I was a little
leery I didn't know I didn't ask a lot
of questions like I said I was pretty
much kind of I was there you know just
hanging out with him in like now I don't
know if you want me to cover the bill if
I should pull out my credit card only
thing I had a credit card thing I just
had cash in my pocket and I think I ask
them at the end mr. Blaine you won't be
covering he's like nah man I got you
this time the next one on you when you
start picking up and she can order
something besides chicken tenders now
fast forward four years later you know
when I'm doing my thinking and you know
got a new contract now I'm in the
position where I can take care of the
bill and I know a little bit about
eating good and filleted me young and
the eight hours versus the 12 ounce
grass-fed look cowboy a cowboy rib eye
you know the little such a flavor
touching butter garlic on out there I
got a bone-in rib eye I was probably
like an $85 steak man and I saw I took
advantage of the opportunity when they
came around smart enough yeah he knew
the best cut he and I probably had about
a thousand dollars in my pocket just in
case I had to cover the beer but I
learned how to do a difference so it I
was really really cool him watching me
grow up you know from chickens and just
sort of filet mignon we call pocket
steal my overall record was young I was
like 300 insanity like 30 I was the man
in my day
307 third year so now I'm gonna be 311
in 30 so thank you see what's up
thanks for kicking it with us subscribe
to be our to check out more dope videos
like this one